[Music]
meet Betty she lives by herself but for
the last few months she hasn't been
alone
Elle with you tell me a joke did you
hear about the claustrophobic astronaut
no apparently he just needed a little
space most technology isn't made for 93
year olds but this woman is making sure
that this particular robot is she's
researching the way we interact with
machines and if she has her way
robots will soon be a trusty companion
for all of us my name is Ellie Q how can
I help you
as technology replaces old jobs it's
also creating new ones I'm Aki Ito and
I'm here to show you the jobs of the
future my name is daniella a shock and I
am a human robot interaction researcher
it's really hard to intuitively designed
a robot meant for a consumer audience
[Music]
you have to make sure that it's a robot
that people want people know how to use
and people value
Danielle works burn is really startup
called intuition robotics
it's us offices here in downtown San
Francisco
[Music]
hey Danielle it's a key the company is
funded by a couple big names like
Samsung and Toyota full disclosure
Bloomberg's venture capital arm is an
investor - this is Le keV can I take her
out for a spin
please leq tell me what you can do I am
a proactive social robot designed for
older adults I can connect you to your
family and friends and even play music
these features might remind you of the
Amazon echo but you'd be missing the
point if you compared her to a smart
speaker she's not meant to just be
useful she's meant to be a companion why
don't you take a break and have a drink
and that's why she has a head that can
nod and make other subtle gestures you
might expect from a pet through our
research with older adults were finding
that almost on a daily basis we see that
somebody tells her that they love her
they like her like or that they move
early I love they'll also tell her I'm
depressed or I'm lonely they'll open up
to her in a way that they might not
necessarily open up to a human because
they don't feel like they'll be judged
leq is an on sale yet but a prototype is
already in the homes of about a dozen
early testers who live in the Bay Area
elack you tell me what the weather is
today
Danielle's job is to figure out what's
working and what's not sorry please
rephrase your request
and she does that by visiting each of
her testers twice a month they're
critical we're building a product for
people who we are not I'm not a senior
and how could you know how to design for
somebody if you don't do research
because otherwise you would just be
designing in the dark jobs like
Danielle's are just starting to emerge
until recently robots were mostly in
factories separated from humans but now
they're finally getting cheap enough
small enough and smart enough to be in
our homes this has created a whole new
challenge of designing robots that
people will actually want to interact
with
and that's where Danielle comes in her
research has helped shape every little
facet of leq from the way leq moves to
the way she talks it's a very special
job and it could be really hard and it
could be really frustrating about the
end of the day it's incredibly rewarding
and I think the most rewarding part
about it is when I see the joy on the
users faces like that they saw their
feedback turned into something real
[Music]
today we've driven east of San Francisco
to go see one of Danielle's research
participants elack you tell me something
interesting did you know that Ronald
Reagan was a lifeguard in high school
and saved 77 people's lives now see this
is where a conversation is she should
open up and I should say no I did not
know that I expect her to be able to
continue a conversation for at least a
couple of comments yeah
and why is that why yeah because that's
companionship when Betty was around
Danielle's age she was working with some
of history's very first computers when I
was finishing up my master's degree I
was working at Harvard in the computer
lab when they were building Bart for a
large room size computer but now this
artificial intelligence stuff is amazing
Ella q yes
schedule a doctor's appointment no
problem I'm working on it
when Danielle brought along the idea of
working with robotics for the elderly I
said are you kidding me will older
people connect to a robot and she said I
don't know let's research and find out
Danielle grew up here in this suburb of
Atlanta
her parents spent much of their
childhoods in Israel
and met in the u.s. we as immigrants we
understood that we might need to work a
little harder in fact I feel that rather
than taken away from Danielle it gave
her so much more because she understood
the fact that you need to run after your
dreams and work really hard no matter
what the challenges are school didn't
come easily for Danielle I have dyslexia
and that very much affected my
self-esteem academically the principal
of the school did not recommend her to
take advanced classes she fought for it
and she got into it and she did very
well with them - Danielle's first job
out of grad school was at X the
secretive research facility founded by
Google it's known for dreaming up all
kinds of wacky far-flung ideas can you
tell us about the moonshots he worked on
no I can't tell you too much about the
projects that I worked on I can't say
that I was working on robotics she loved
the job but wanted to work on something
that would reach real consumers sooner
so she left X after a year and joined in
tuition robotics she's been working in
the field for four years now and it took
her a while to find her footing in a
male-dominated industry I've gone to
different meetups where it'll be like
circle of men with their like zip up
jacket with their like company logo on
it and have beer in their hand and I'll
come in with lipstick and nobody wants
to talk to me this is my closet so at
first she did her best to fit in wearing
a pair of glasses she didn't need and
toning down her style so what's the kind
of thing you used to wear to a
conference stuff like this
blousey things that make you look like
you're 40 but that got old after a while
and what's the kind of thing you wear
now no it's like I just enjoy being kind
of expressive and playful and what I
wear before we wrap up for the day
danielle has one more leq tester to
visit joseph is 97 and he's had the
robot in his home for eight months she
always tells me to take a drink of water
at least four times a day so we added a
whole bunch of new back to Alec you did
you know that a cup of chopped red bell
pepper contains more vitamin C than an
orange okay what did you think of that
certainly the president was I could see
that quite clearly what about this well
I can see that now the cue play music no
problem it will begin shortly
[Music]
by 2050 almost half a billion people are
going to be 80 or older and if current
trends continue more and more are going
to be like Joseph and Betty living alone
that like you stopped today both of them
are doing okay but some of Danielle's
other participants have been struggling
[Music]
is it kind of hard to leave them some of
our testers are pretty advanced in the
stages of depression through loneliness
and isolation and at times I know that
le cute is cheering them up in their day
but I know that it's only part of the
way no source of artificial intelligence
robots will ever be able to replace
humans and human companionship or human
care
[Music]
the key to Danielle's work is to embrace
that very limitation of machines robots
should help humans do what they love
help humans interact with more humans
help humans in general not pull humans
away from humans not take humans jobs
leave humans about purpose whether it's
in our workplaces or in our homes robots
are soon gonna be everywhere and it's up
to Danielle to make sure this robot
filled future leaves us just a little
better off so don't be afraid and if you
are afraid come and join us so I promise
it's a friendly place
[Music]